[Music]
good morning everyone and thanks for
coming out my name is Finn Hamner and
I'm the CTO of coggle and I'm here to
talk to you today about a broad overview
of our platform and how it may help you
and your day-to-day work but before I
get started I'd like to get a better
understanding of um who's in the room
and what's her background is so I'm
gonna ask a series of questions about
your exposure to coggle so far and I
want to raise your hand if you're
familiar have done some of these actions
in cattle first so first can you raise
your hand if you've heard of cattle okay
I might have to stop asking that
question because they think that was the
entire room can you keep her hand up if
you have a cattle account Wow okay about
three quarters of the room probably then
who has downloaded data from cattle
probably about half the room now and who
has entered a cattle competition before
cool about 30% of the room maybe who has
won a cattle competition or one prize
money in a cattle competition one person
at least awesome I can have you come up
and give the talk instead and then have
you written in red coat on cattle
through cattle card also raise your head
if you have okay about ten people maybe
about 5% of the room and then have you
found cackled helpful to learn about
data and machine learning okay about
probably 40% of the room and then
finally where you do use calculus your
primary resource when you're starting
your journey into data science and
machine learning or starting to work
with data three or four people okay cool
so it's one of rare people thanks for
that to get started and then I'm as a
bit of background tokugawa is the
world's largest online community of data
scientists machine learning engineers
and engineers and we have about 2.8
million users who come to a Kaggle for
three main motivations first to learn
and improve their skills working with
data and start
to work on machine learning and AI
problems through a mix of learning from
content that we create content that our
users publish as well as competitions
that we put up that provide great test
beds for sharpening your skills secondly
to compete in the machine learning
competitions that we host and
demonstrate how your methodologies and
techniques work in a fair playing ground
to evaluate them compared to thousands
of other users around the world and then
finally to collaborate on data and AI
projects as an individual or as part of
small teams as you work on analyze
airing and collaborating a code to
analyze data and we started hosting AI
competitions in 2010 and for most of our
history we've been really focused on
hosting these competitions where
companies nonprofits and research groups
would come to us with a large number of
machine learning challenges alongside
datasets to address these challenges and
then we'd collaborate with them to
define well structured AI problems on
those two assets and then post them to
our community within participate in
these competitions and develop solutions
on these datasets and that provided a
really great way to gain insights into
how the how machine learning was
evolving as well as frictions that users
hit as they're trying to apply machine
learning to real problems and based on
those pain points and insights that we
saw we started to expand our platform
into our community beyond competitions
in 2015 with the launch of a
reproducible research platform in a
public data platform as well as in 2018
the on launch of a Learning Resource so
I'm going to dive deeper into each of
these parts of goggle and as I do this I
encourage you to think about how you can
leverage our platform to accelerate your
own data and machine learning work
professionally so first as an
introduction what is a Kaggle
competition um we run dozens of pala
competitions simultaneously many with
large amounts of prize money attached to
them and each of these competition this
has a very well-defined AI problem now
let's walk you through a simple exam
first this is on applying regression
techniques as a getting started tutorial
competition to predict the house prices
and we'll start with a data set from a
competition host with a target variable
on it so in this case we're trying to
project the steel price of a home based
on a small number of things like the
number size of the home that whether
it's a homework a dominium the size of a
lot it's on things like that we will
take the data set from the competition
host and figure out a good way to split
into a train set and a test set we will
then release the train set and all but
the solution on the test set to our
community who will then train models on
the training set and make predictions on
the test set and then submit their
predictions back to us we will compare
their predictions to the ground truth
and then calculate scores based on those
predictions on a public in private
leader board then the really important
part of this is participants see
real-time feedback on how they're doing
in the competition on the public leader
board both their own score and
performance in the competition as well
as how this compares to every other
participant in it and this creates the
dynamic that really drives the progress
of the competition fords because it's
the difference between a user making one
or two passes and the problem feeling
pretty good about themselves are pretty
bad all themselves and giving up in
saying like oh wow how did this guy get
or on this person get ahead of me and
then wanting to try improving the
results to match or beat the performance
of the people in front of them and
overtime this dynamic drives the
competition to extract nearly all the
usable signal from the data set
potentially limited by the inherent
noise in the problem as well as any
limitations in the current state of the
art and the machine learning so what
this graph is going to show is it's
going to graph on the competition
progress over time and the top score on
the public leaderboard over time so what
typically happens is pretty quickly we
get a submission that's a decent
improvement over the benchmark in the
competition and then that submission is
being Bice another submission that is
also a pretty large improvement in this
state a vacant Lea probably occurs
a couple times early in the competition
until we hit a point where it's very
very tough to improve the results beyond
that even with an increasing number of
teams participating in people trying to
tackle this problem we don't see a large
increase in performance and this is a
really promising sign that we've hit the
limit of what is achievable on this data
set given the current limitations of the
state of the art as well as any inherent
noise in the data set and this is a sign
if you're managing a team of machine
learning engineers as well that you
don't want to invest more and trying to
improve the machine learning piece of
this problem maybe if you're trying to
improve wheel performance beyond that
you should be collecting a lot more
training data or you should be doing
some other aspects of the problem it
isn't based on the current data said
that we have to work with then another
really unique aspects of competitions is
even though there's a competitive
dynamic driving them most participants
in the competition are not trying to win
they're coming to learn and improve
their skills and this results in a
highly highly collaborative helpful and
detail-oriented competition forums where
people are sharing what techniques work
well on the problem as well as insights
that they've learned as well as if they
get stuck I'm helping other users get
unstuck and this is just a quick example
of some forum post that you'll see that
I have really practical detailed tips
required to do well in the problem
versus fraud statements and then at the
end of the competition final results are
unveiled on a private leader board for
both prize money as well as recognition
and to take a step back probably the
most famous competition or the most
famous machine learning algorithm in the
u.s. is the Zillow's Zestimate score for
house estimating house prices and we
collaborated with Zillow at a
competition recently that involved
predicting future house price sales and
out of time samples and this actually
improved on the Zestimate by 13% so this
is provides a really concrete example of
how this dynamic can help improve real
old machine learning results if we look
at user profiles on cackle
users profile will highlight their best
cago results in really showcase here's
how well they can perform on applied
machine learning problems and can be a
critical part to helping many of our
users find jobs saying transition into
the field and get hired and alongside
this we maintain a global ranking of all
top carol competitors over time the next
question I want to tackle is what use
cases do our customers
tackle with cataleya competitions and my
goal is to give a broad overview now of
the different use cases that we tackle
this isn't going to cover everything but
it's going to be a representative sample
the first set that's become really
prominent in recent years based on the
combination of the success of deep
learning as well as wildly available
image datasets and cost effective human
labeling has fostered a large growth in
computer vision competitions and these
range from image classification object
boundary to detection and an object
recognition to environmental problems
like detect facial recognition and
whales or counting how many sea lions
that you see in images they're subset of
this category I'm personally really
excited about is using automated
methodologies to improve medical imaging
results and start to tackle the
challenge that we only have a very small
number of trained physicians in the
world who can relative to the size of
the global population who can read these
images and that myth means that we're
missing results of a huge fraction of
the population what an example of that
was we collaborated with a company
called mobile OTT that's developing a
device that can be attached to a cell
phone for cervical cancer imaging and
then can flag if it's for patients in
rural Africa if they should be seeing a
doctor in a follow-up visit and going to
an urban City to see a doctor and a
follow-up visit on that a third broad
category look moving back to the online
world is around recommender systems and
personalised recommenders
systems where these have been very
effective at improving results ranging
from consumer products to things are you
directly useful for machine learning
engineers as well like recommending
which are packages you should be using
in your day to day work another and
distinct and more challenging stead is
forecasting Proctor to me and over time
on out of time samples where you can no
longer make the assumption that past
performance or past results are going to
be drawn from the same distribution of
the future results and this introduces a
really complex time element into the
machine learning models in the fork the
forecasts that need to be done for
tackling these challenges another broad
category that is a really important
challenge to solve is improving your
ability to apply automated methods for
text in speech understanding especially
with a large increase in online content
recently and everything that that
entails and then finally looking at more
industrial abuse cases we've started to
see an increasing number of predictive
maintenance use cases where at
predicting which parts will require
maintenance over time in advance of the
mate profiling in the maintenance being
required so next I want to look at what
insights have we learned from seeing how
users approach these competitions and to
the first is probably everyone's
favorite topic when they look at what
works well in machine learning which is
what tools and which techniques work
well over the past several years that
has a had a really pithy summary and
that there's two types of techniques
that have been on me present and winning
a lot of different types and diverse
types of goggle competitions the first
are flavors of unsolved decision trees
like gradient boosted machines with
extra boost is one of the really common
successful high quality implementations
of that and then secondly deep neural
networks for richly structured natural
input like computer vision data with
Kerris as being one example
of a really popular library implementing
that and we actually I'm recently
surveyed Kaggle winner since 2016 for
which primary ml frameworks where they
using and then you see this coming out
here where we have three deep learning
frameworks
that's stood out as the primary
framework the winners have used harris
pi torch and tensorflow and then to
ensemble decision tree great boosting
machine framework slide GBM and extra
boost and these are so widely used both
because of their ease of use and ease of
getting started on challenges as well as
the ability to go really deep and
iterate quickly and expose the
complexity when you need it in improving
the machine learning algorithms that
you're using to tackle the specific
problem
we also added a secondary question to
the bat survey for what exhilarate mo
software tools are you also using to
compete in competitions and the one that
really stood out here is aam
scikit-learn was rarely used as the
primary tool by the winners however the
feature pre-processing in the feature
selection and ensemble and techniques
that were present in it we're a highly
helpful auxilary tool for our different
winners from a process standpoint we've
also had one clear lesson that has stood
out from hundreds of winners interviews
and that is the people who do well at
applied machine learning
do not take a complex idea then try that
one complex idea over three months to
twelve month time period because a lot
of ideas that we start off with our bad
instead what they do is they optimize
their workflow for learning in
experimenting through a lot of bad ideas
to find the ones that actually work or
start working well and then really
honing in on the ideas that work well so
instead of trying to implement one
complex large and complex idea they
instead try many ideas over time
implement them quickly take rigorous
evaluation evaluate how they work
analyze their results and where they
learned then go through this cycle again
and again and again and the teams that
perform well are the teams
are effective at both going through the
cycle many times as well as playing
close attention to what they were
learning from going through the cycle
and in a similar vein this iteration is
not just done on the singly or machine
learning component instead for any
applied AI model you go from a into an
component from a business problem to a
production system that includes finding
source statuses to use how do you split
the data in order to do your internal
evaluation as well as your final
evaluation samples which evaluation
metrics to use how do you extract
features and select features how do you
train your model how do you do model
selection and then finally how do you
implement that in a production system
our competition still currently tackle
the first piece in the last piece of
that in darker blue but we have caught
some of her competitions tackle the into
n pieces in between those and it's
critical to optimize those entire
workflows not just that machine learning
piece in the middle there and given this
rapid iteration and a large number of
experiments that our users are running
another key piece that successful
participants do is they keep very
careful track of all their experimental
results for their learning as well as
using version control so they can scroll
back at a point in time when they need
to go back to an idea that had some
promise and pull that back up and really
understand what it worked about it and
quite ov that another piece that and
this has been true for almost all of the
several hundred general competitions
that we've run is that they've been won
by large ensembles of models versus a
single model and it's these large
ensembles almost always eke out a very
marginal additional gain so it's like
the single best model and there might be
99.9 or 99.5% of the best performance
than that additional point five percent
performance improvement comes from
taking a large number of different
complex models and combining them all
together which is great for squeezing
out the last bit of predictive accuracy
but putting my software engineering hat
on it's about the last thing I'd want to
put into production so instead
focus on that single best performing
model within that ensemble that is the
one that made more sense to put in
production another lesson that we've
learned is successful participants very
carefully analyze how does theirs model
generalize in new data points and avoid
try avoiding overfitting one of our
users learned this lesson the hard way
would each watched himself fall off the
leader board in the final minute of the
competition when transition from though
public leaderboards to the holdout set
in the private leader board and I don't
think he's overfitting competition since
then so we're gonna talk a little bit
more about where we are going with
tackle AI competitions every comes
almost every competition that we've run
so far has been of the form we have a
training data set a test a set users
download the training data set make
predictions in the trade a model in the
training data set they prediction from
the tacit an upload their protection
Chicago uploading predictions is
limiting in a number of ways so we're
starting to expand to the competitions
that we're hosting beyond or uploading
predictions and to running uploading
code and using the code as a submission
um so the way this works first a small
number of competitions now is users will
write the code to train the model and
make predictions of it through a host of
chemical a code execution service that
we run and then submit that code to
tackle a couple examples of this where
it's been really helpful to enable us to
run these competitions in a high power
quality way is two of them have touched
on back testing and forecasting time
series in a financial modeling problem
where for any time series challenge you
don't want to have a single train to us
and test asset and instead you want to
stream the data into the model over time
and make predictions going forward at
each time increment
it's also helped us run more effective
competitions around challenges where a
human could go through and label the
answers to the results because we can
now run competitions and hidden test
assets where a human can actually go
through and hand label the results the
test hit
like for a text or image competitions
and then finally it's let us experiment
with competitions around ever cereal or
we have a really fun cat-and-mouse
dynamic where let's say that I have a
picture of a cat and I want to trick
that my classifier into thinking this is
a picture of a dog not a cat by making
small imperceptible modifications to
that picture and then we rate a series
of competitions around predicting models
that modify images to trick classifiers
as well as models that should be
classify those images and be robust
against this adversarial attacks and in
the future this will unlock a bunch of
exciting new flavors of AI competitions
ranging from back test and time series
and live day data feeds to reinforcement
learning challenges for instead of
machine learning model making
predictions you have an agent that's
taking actions and interacting with an
environment in a score based on how it
interacts with that environment over
time as well as generative modeling
competitions where you are creating new
images or new text samples and
evaluating whether or not those images
or text samples mirror their real
distributions diversity learn learning
competitions as another one that he
mentioned another area that's become
increasingly important as machine
learnings moved off out of research in
into many applications to other world is
machine learning under computational
constraints because if you're
implementing machine learning at scale
it is very costly to do the machine
learning predictions and takes up both
in terms of dollars and energy usage as
well as there's a lot of scenarios where
you watched very low latency and low
energy predictions for example I could
have the best speech recognition model
in the world but if I'm in a low
connectivity scenario with my cell phone
that model is useless to me if they
can't run quickly on my phone and then
finally it'll let us run competitions on
sensitive data sets where we cannot
release the data said publicly but
instead we can bring the code in the
models to the data sets privately no as
I mentioned before we spent most of the
past decade or so focused on building
and expanding AI competitions in the
community around such but
recently we've been expelled ngey and AI
competitions as well I want to talk a
little bit about our motivations for
that so the global community that we
built around competitions has provided a
lot of insight for current frictions on
applying a I through on our experience
working with hundreds of host
organizations around the world and
seeing their frictions that they
structured and creating machine learning
problems employing the data sets for
those from our experience in working
with our users and saying how they
started tackling problems and all the
frictions they hit doing things like
sharing code with each other as well as
from our own internal work you know
summarize some of the ones have served
as inspiration for me and for us as we
start to expand beyond competitions the
first is that we've hit many barriers to
accessing data which still lives in
silos within different organizations in
many different forms and then once we do
have access to that data under seeing
the context behind the data makes you
feel like a detective and getting get
that out into a high quality state it
can be really tough for a couple of
examples that we've hit trying to clean
data one of them is I was working with a
data set of flight arrival and departure
times for train miles to predict how
long a flight will take and then on the
first pass of it I was surprised to see
that I had a bunch of flights that had
negative duration then I was thinking oh
okay must have had messed up the times
in processing in my code or something
like that I look at that no time zones
were right including for flights taking
off and landing in the time zone flight
of a reason there's just a couple
percentage of these flights that were
late it put it incorrectly as actually
lading before they took off which made
no sense as a another and then I'm
trying if we're trying to make a model
perfect predict flight durations and I
naively throw a bunch of flights with
negative duration in there that'll throw
my entire results way off there's
another example I was working with it a
set of bulldozer prices in weather
fields as an input into that
the year the bulldozer was manufactured
was flipping through down and see things
like 1983 1995 1972 and thank you okay
this makes sense they start seeing a
bunch of fields that say 1000 1000 1000
boulders word didn't exist before the
steam engine I'm and did exist in the
air 1000 it turns out that somewhere in
the complex set of processes to create
that data set um from a lot of different
sources one person decided do you know
what 1,000 is a great number to use this
missing value so 1000 just meant that
they didn't know when it was
manufactured it is a third example we
were working with the Dow a set of
essays that we armed student essays the
way transcribers go and digitized those
with the instructions that if he can't
read the essay please throw it out in
doats and just the data back for that
and mark it is ami can't read it and
said we're starting to train some
baseline miles on this and so that there
was one essay in there that and these
were supposed to be about a thousand
word essays that just said this has it
got good marks but as far as I can tell
it's gibberish that scored very highly
and if I'd actually thrown that into a
machine learning ball with a small very
small number of data sets that would
have really thrown my model off because
the it was a case where the transcriber
didn't follow the instructions then
pretty much any data problem like this
has a large number of examples where you
really need to dig deep into that asset
to understand the context behind its
create it's great and what errors may
exist with it to successfully apply
machine learning models that work well
on it and another flavor of that is
understanding which forms of leakage may
emerge near dassit it's a really common
and subtle problem for a lot of machine
learning applications leakage is where
you're trying to use information to make
predictions on the new samples that you
don't actually have at the time of
making predictions and new samples or as
invalid to use for predictions and new
samples and one example of this is we
got a data set a while ago on prostate
cancer surgery or pressing cancer
prediction and trying to predict whether
the likelihood of a patient have
prostate cancer
had a couple hundred fields in there
with the kyv obscurely names that we
didn't know what they meant so we
trained a baseline model on it then
looked at what was driving the results
and it turns out this innocuously name
feature Pross surge was buried in the
middle of that that represented this
patient had had surgery for prostate
cancer so it's highly highly predictive
of whether or not the Cape a Shinto was
likely to have prostate cancer but was
entirely useless in applying it in any
new patient scenario then another have
common pain points that we've seen is
reproducing other's work can take a very
long time whether it's work that I'm
going back to work that I did four years
ago I'm trying to work take work that my
colleague did and run it on my machine
or trying to well even worse starting
with a rated paper that's published
online that I'm really interested in I
don't have the code data or maybe even
the computational equipment that was
used to produce that and trying to
reproduce those results so this is
probably one of the largest waste of
human capital and resources in our field
and that we spend a tremendous amount of
time simply trying to get to the same
result that someone else had I'm in
working through package conflicts
version conflicts different data sets
and a large set of errors
they're simply to reproduce work that
someone else had already did that pre
consists to the first product that we
launched to try starting to address some
of these pain points I assume a lot of
the frictions I mentioned as like
aspirational long-term goals and if we
can even make a small dent into those
then we can create some real good in the
world so first we've launched a feature
called cattle cartel so we can now click
new cartel on any competition or data
set on cattle and this will enable you
to spin up in an interactive script or
notebook a session in Python or R on
that data set and in a docker container
and you within seconds will have a
source code editor an interactive
console in there all day
at your fingertips so you don't have to
do things like install.packages because
we have most of the Python in our
package the open-source package
ecosystems installed in therefore you
need to have to worry about downloading
the data are going and getting the data
or anything like that it's also easy to
moderate things like your compute usage
and add GPUs or additional compute if
you need to in this and after you
finished code coding or get to a
stopping point you can click commit and
then create a shareable and reproducible
version of your work in a clean
environment the reason we rerun things
in clean environments is I've seen a lot
of Jupiter notebooks where it might have
15 cells in it but those 15 cells have
been around about a thousand times and
that what was in the cell was no
included a lot of hidden stage that was
necessary to reproduce to work so it's
not actually reproducible and then from
here you can share your kernel with
collaborators or make it public and
share it with our Kamiya community and
then we've had now about a very large
number of high quality kernels shared
publicly on toggle over about 200,000
now of which about 50,000 have at least
one upvote from another user as a rough
indication for like another user found
this valuable and this is a higher
quality result and in practice this
means we have a really rich array of
content for basically any type of data
that you might be working with and
machine learning problem or
visualization problem that you might be
trying to tackle you can find an example
of how to do that in a public data set
on goggle so it's helped provide a
really rich way of tutorials that you
can use to get started with and
furthermore because of this is being
backed by version to compute version
data and version code it's
straightforward to repeat for others
hurdles that they have shared here and
reproduce the work that they created as
well as interact with their examples and
extend it into your own so I see a
kernel as combining the three critical
components for reproducible to a science
the first is version
code the second is version data and the
third is a version computational
environment through docker containers
then things on Kevlar are mostly
reproducible in the sense that you can
still do things like not said the
erratum seed or if you're using
parallelism a lot of them functions that
use parallelism have a dependency in the
time they take to execute and 4-doors
also return so it's not reproducible in
that sense but it's reproducible in many
of the course and that brings us to the
one of the next questions we face while
we've launched kernels and competitions
but I want to loan you data into that
kernel as well how do I do that
and that led us to launch goggle
datasets for two different reasons
the first was to provide a version of
reproducible data store to load data
into kernels those straightforward to
drag files up and drop them in where
they're there in a version way for
future use and then secondly to provide
a interface where as easy to share data
in a high-quality way to the rest of the
world and over the past couple years
this has grown really dramatically about
15,000 data sets have now been publicly
shared on goggle and my longer-term goal
is to have all the public data in the
world accessible through a common
interface like this I'm so I no longer
if I'm trying to work with weather data
for example have to go to an FTP server
from NOAA to try getting that obscure
weather time trying to pull in or trying
to dig through a complex data dictionary
from the census to understand what does
this field in this since this is one of
the most commonly used assets mean then
all of these dossett's are downloadable
and browsable in a web UI and we're
really targeting making these - that's
easy to consume both for humans and
machines so the machine piece is
connecting it to cattle curdles and for
ease of use for consumption in python
and r and the human piece is providing
clear summaries of what's in the data
for things like histograms on the number
of unique values in a field the number
of missing fellows in the field as a
well as collaborative human right and
descriptions of like what's the disk
Alamein what does this file mean what's
in this file and components along those
lines and these does that's linked all
the codes that users have publicly
shared on top of them as well so when if
you go and publish it out on goggle you
get the advantage of seeing how that is
used and how other users have built on
your data set and created code on your
data set and then if you're trying to
get started on the data set then you
don't just start with an Excel
spreadsheet or a CSV file or the file
itself instead you start with here's a
thousand different code examples that
other users have written on it for how
to read that out and how to visualize it
how to pre-process it how to apply
machine learning other algorithms to it
and things along those lines inch then
after we started to build up these all
these resources and create all this
content and catechol we started to get
the question more and more I want to get
started with machine learning and I do
not know where to go what should I do
and that led us to start building a
series of micro courses with tutorials
interactive exercises with a goal of
providing a really fast and
straightforward way for users to get
started with in the nearest way possible
to get them on to their own projects in
their own work um so these range from
beginner content like Python and my
interest in machine learning and data
visualization and on pandas is a really
nice data [ __ ] duplication library and
Python to more advanced contents like
machine learning explained ability of
course where we want to really help
users understand that the fact I'm
seeing machine learning Mahalo says
black boxes is a really common
misconception and there's a large number
of tools and methodologies available to
you to introspect machine learning law
and understand what is driving its
performance and why is it making the
predictions that it is so that was a
broad overview of the different pieces
of catalyst platform I hope that was
helpful for you to understand
the different components of what we're
working on and why we're working on them
as well as we are search trying to solve
your next machine learning or data
problem hopefully this will be a helpful
resource for you to go to and fight a
example as a source of inspiration or
see how another user has tried to tackle
a similar problem as you and use that as
a starting point versus needing to start
your work from a blinking cursor
[Music]